welcome back alad ab elfata has been in
and out of an egyptian jail since 2011
an activist he had a prominent role in
the arab spring uprising after an appeal
from the united nations he was released
but he's currently serving time in
prison for a facebook post criticizing
the government his family are trying to
get help from the uk government to get
him freed earlier i spoke to his sister
sana currently living in the uk
and once arrested and imprisoned herself
about their campaign
sandy thanks for coming on the show
today um we want to talk about your
story today but i want to talk to you
first about your brother allah who's
detained in egypt um
before we get on to what's happening
with him can you tell me a bit about him
thank you for having me
ale
publicly is known to be a
programmer uh
writer
uh and
a pro-democracy secular human rights
activist yeah but as a person like as a
brother he's um he's my older brother
i'm the the baby sister
so
we're friends but there's also this
mentorship kind of uh
dynamic
he's um
he's the person in the family who's he's
he's a bit of an
he's always been kind of a nerd he likes
to read a lot he's
about everything to know engage with
everything can you tell me sort of what
happened to him and how he ended up in
prison how he got out of prison and why
he's back in prison now we were
interested in the political situation
in egypt
my father my belief father was a human
rights lawyer and ale because he was a
programmer and technologist he was
really interested in
empowering uh people uh like
localizing tools making them available
in arabic and by by by that empowering
people to
to communicate and to organize that was
pre
pre the like the social media movement
and so when 2011 happened he kind of
became a prominent figure because of the
work he did in the bloggers movement
and um with the family background
we gained some prominence
and then in 2013 when the when the
backlash happened and the military
uh
basically
took charge
we became one of the
as a family but especially we became one
of the main targets of the regime so he
he went to prison in in
2011 he was he was released and he's now
back in prison why does president sisi
see him as such a threat because he
means something to other people that
he's a symbol of what rebellion of an
alternative future
he seems to be a real threat to the
government or they perceive him to be
yeah it's something that this we don't
know for sure why
i mean
our assessment is that they kind of
we had the little we were known by a few
people before the attack like the
vicious attack happened to us in 2013
but i think they kind of created their
own uh
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
they
because they tried to set an example
with ale and so they've so viciously
attacked him and um
was
sentenced to five years for a
demonstration and a demonstration he he
did not
organize or the organizers actually
went to court and showed evidence that
they are the organizers and the court
decided to uh to to to dismiss
that so he served five years for that
and he started fighting and then he came
and he came out and then he re-arrested
him again and put him on youtube
for for a facebook post uh a facebook
post he did not write a facebook post he
shared about human rights
have violations happening in a prison so
it the details are could could be
confusing and
are not confusing but exhausting
to tell and to listen to but
but i think it's that so you sorry keeps
building up so he was falsely so the so
there was what it was a false
imprisonment the second well the first
time you would argue it was a false
imprisonment but the second time they
kind of constructed a case to to to
re-arrest him yeah both time constructed
and
actually in egypt
it's quite a known fact now that the
legal uh
things are just details that
everybody knows the ale is not so
technically allah is imprisoned for a
facebook post
but everybody knows that genuinely and
is not imprisoned for a facebook post so
he's in prison because he represents
something he represents
um
something for for a younger generation
how's he doing in prison have you seen
him
last time i saw allah was in march
before i left cairo my sister saw him
last week um so the way we see allah is
for the past three years the visits are
behind the glass shield with a phone
speaker
um
in april 2nd he
he started a hunger strike
so today would be
the 75 of his hunger strike i haven't
seen him since the hunger strike but
what my sister explains to me is really
terrifying
because i was outside the country
last visit my sister came out type what
i called i called her and my mom
they really sounded distressed they said
he looks very weak
it's like his only skin on bones
mona my sister because of
because of how shocked she was she
couldn't eat since
and she just told me i i feel like i
have to use my body as a portal
to show that what's happening to ale
because
the egyptian authorities are are
are are using
uh the fact that they can hide him in a
in a dark cell and not show to them
today would be her fourth day
um
that's difficult okay well sorry you
should explain from the beginning right
it's fine it's fine
um
okay so what led to the strike
was that
for the past few years his conditions
were really really bad he wasn't allowed
anything he was
isolated from any outside input so he
wasn't allowed books time outside of his
cell
he would they wouldn't even allow him a
clock to be aware of the time of the day
right
and
he was in a maximum security prison that
is built on the whole premise of the war
on terrorism while he's not on terrorism
charges he's actually on a misdemeanor
and it's a freedom of expression issue
but it's also like legally in his
demeanor
um
so
we kept on
filing complaints but but it led to
nothing so allah decided
he was feeling really that
because in prison you don't have agency
over anything but your body yeah so when
he was totally fed up when he couldn't
take it anymore he decided to start a
hunger strike yeah
understand that yeah so for on day 55
when when they made this little
compromise from their behalf he also
made a little compromise and started
taking 100 calories a day he said i
switched to a gandhi style strike right
okay so a human being should take around
2000 calories a day it takes 100
calories
um if his conditions improve or if he
gets consumer access he could make more
compromises just before we get to
his release and your campaign i just
wanted to ask you
about your time in prison because
you know far you were also arrested
weren't you can you tell us what
happened to you
yeah so
um i i was imprisoned uh over the past
10 years three times
each of those times has a story but they
all come down to one thing to
the fact that as family we're being
punished because we're vocal about the
assaults or the
violations that happened to ali
so this last time i served a year and a
half sentence i was arrested after
trying to to get a letter into my
brother let's get back to your brother
he spent a lot of time in detention uh
he's got a sentence until 2027
i believe um how
hopeful
are you of of getting him out and have
you received any assistance from the uk
government to help you your mother was
born
in the uk and you are all due citizens
and so he does fall under the remit
of the uk government
yeah i'm for the first time now
in the last nine years i'm actually very
hopeful although we are at a moment of
desperation but we also at the moment of
possibility
um
alex case is very complicated if you
think of it locally but
there is precedence
uh
and there is a law that was issued in
2015.
uh for dual nationals for specifically
cases like ale and there is president
with the us
with australia and with france
uh that uh
they would basically for political
prisoners
they would basically renounce their
other citizenship and be deported to
their other country of residence and and
and of course
in our last case if he would if he was
deported here
none of the the case file here wouldn't
be i mean he wouldn't be considered a
criminal
and this is obviously a freedom of
expression issue you need the foreign
secretary to get involved yes we need to
we need the foreign secretary and i'm
and i'm confused i'm not sure why
because
i can see that there is a lot of
sympathy i can see that
there is support we're always in touch
with the embassy
um and so i'm confused as to why we
haven't met with the foreign secretary
yet so you haven't met with the foreign
secretary if you could ask the prime
minister or the foreign secretary liz
truss to do one thing what would it be
to
well
to to meet with us
basically but ultimately i know that
a firm phone call
from the prime minister
followed by
a robust negotiation from the fcdo we'll
get our out
i know that we've seen that with the
french we've seen that
with the americans you've recently
joined forces with richard ratcliffe and
you've also just had more than a
thousand celebrities from dame judi
dench to mark ruffalo carrie mulligan
urgent uh liz truster foreign secretary
um and the u.s used council anthony
blinken to use their diplomatic force to
try and
get your brother freed
um you've got momentum now
but you still think the british
government aren't really listening is it
just not a priority for them because
they've got other more important in
their
views
i'm really confused that's why i'm
really confused i see sympathy and we
have momentum and we have solidarity and
support for from other uh governments in
the west
and
relationships between egypt and britain
are very strong this is not something
that's going to jeopardize those
relationships actually this gives
the uk leverage
uh
that's why i am i'm genuinely puzzled as
to why we're not getting the attention
we need
from the foreign secretary how hopeful
are you that you might be able to see
your brother not behind
a glass
partition but actually face to face by
the end of this year say
again i'm i'm now hopeful more than ever
um ale is not unfortunately
but i understand that from his
perspective
alle believes he's gonna die in prison
um
i'm hopeful i'm really hopeful and i and
i think it's easy it's simple if we get
to the right people
and i think
there is precedence
um
we know the recipe
as to how to do it french did it the us
did it and uk is definitely capable of
doing it
okay
well sana thank you so much for telling
us your story and um and i hate your
brother i hope your brother gets out
soon and
gets healthy and gets to see you and his
son and and all his family again thank
you thank you thank you for having me